so we can never question the New York
Times so the Washington Post or The Wall
Street Journal they always get it right
ok that's an interesting theory but it
did you really catch what he said
what's karma on the rest of these
opportunists are saying is that if you
ever raise doubt about the collusion
narrative
you're either mouthpiece for Putin or
just a trump bootlicker there's no room
for anything in-between
that's how they attempt to smear people
and shut down debate well our next guest
has been a skeptic from the start of
this pro journalist and co-founder of
the intercept Glenn Greenwald joins us
now Glenn we have seen this shift in the
media the same people who were just
exposed now say that either Barr is like
doing running a conspiracy with Trump
and massaging Mulder's findings or that
Muller himself might be in on some type
of conspiracy so what can we expect from
here from the media that got this so
wrong from the start well first of all
if any of those people had any honor
they would go before the camera hang
their head in shame and then apologize
to everybody that they misled for the
last three years and then resign and go
away never to be heard from again but of
course they won't they're addicted to
their paycheck into the bright lights of
the camera so they'll continue to do it
they're kind of like an apocalyptic cult
you know those cult leaders who promise
their followers that the world is going
to end on a certain date and then their
date arrives in the world doesn't end
and all their Confused flock need an
explanation that's what MSNBC and CNN
are facing right now is a very confused
flock of people who kept being told that
it was only a matter of time before Bob
Muller saves them all from the Trump
administration by dragging Trump jr. and
Jared Kushner and everybody else out in
handcuffs and now not only didn't any of
that happen but he specifically found
that there was no collusion the thing
that they were told there wasn't even
any debate about and so what they're
doing now is spinning all new conspiracy
theories it's kind of like a Ponzi
scheme where it keeps collapsing so you
keep having defeated so their argument
now is that oh you know what we haven't
seen the Muller report
we've seen his william bars claims about
what's in it which means they're
implying that probably bob fuller did
find collusion but william bar is lying
about it and for some reason bob muller
and his team of nineteen high-powered
lawyers are totally fine with that
they're just completely silent and
passive as william bar goes around lying
about the last twenty two months of
their work how stupid and gullible do
you have to be to believe that but
that's the desperation CNN MSNBC anchors
having gotten caught with this scam yeah
well speaking of CN n by the way first
of all Chris Cuomo said not a chance
would he ever apologize last night when
Giuliani brought that possibility up he
said not a chance he ridiculed Giuliani
after he left the show which is
low-class
but this is what CNN's coverage looked
like just for people who haven't caught
it over the past two years I want to
read the definition of of treason during
a new word right he said it was treason
right we do know that Donald Trump
senior has lied throughout this
investigation this goes to the heart of
everything we've been talking about for
the last couple of years the collusion
has and the cover-up but yesterday Glenn
the network president Jeff Zucker
defended the network's coverage and he
told the New York Times quote we're not
investigators we're journalists and our
role is to report the facts as we know
them which is exactly what we did a
sitting presidents own Justice
Department investigated his campaign for
collusion with a hostile nation that's
not enormous because the media says so
that's enormous
because it's unprecedented your response
to his defense well Jeff Zucker has no
understanding of what journalism is and
all you have to do is look at the
network that he runs to see that you
want to hear something so interesting
aura I spent a lot of years being on CNN
and MSNBC constantly I used to get
invited on all the time starting in 2017
when I began to express serious
skepticism about their cash cow which
was this hoax this fairy tale this
conspiracy theory that they were
peddling every day they just banned me
from going on their networks and it's
not just me it's other highly
credentialed journalists who were
expressing skepticism like Jeremy
Scahill Matt Taibbi
lots of other people on the Left who are
just banned because they wanted to
deceive their audience into believing
that the only ones who questioned what
they were feeding them were either the
Trump Whitehouse or hardcore Trump
supporters they lied not just to their
audience about what really happened but
they did it on purpose to keep anybody
who is questioning them off the air
there right there are not investigators
they're also not journalists they're
propagandists they're fraudsters they
made lots of money lying to people and
misleading people on purpose and their
entire hoax just got exposed Glenn thank
you very much for